Write 15:25 as a fraction
in simplest form.
So 15 to 25 is just a ratio,
and we can write it.
So they've given us 15 to 25.
And you can write this ratio as
a fraction, as 15 over 25.
And if we want to put this in
simplest form, we just have to
think about what is the largest
number that divides
into both 15 and 25?
Or what is their greatest
common factor?
When you just eyeball it, you
say, well, 5 goes into both of
them, and I'm pretty sure that's
the largest number that
divides into both, so let's
divide both by 5.
If there is a larger number,
then we might be able to see
it once we've simplified
it a little bit more.
So let's divide the numerator
and the denominator by 5 and
see what we get.
So now we get 15 divided
by 5 is equal to 3.
And 25 divided by 5 is equal
to 5, and now we have 3/5.
3 and 5 don't share any common
factors greater than 1, so it
is in simplest form.
So we've done what they asked.
We've written it as a fraction
in simplest form.
We could also write this, if
we want to write it in this
type of notation, as 3:5.